Rishi sunak and his wife akshata Murthy
made time for a visit to a Hindu temple
on the last day of the G20 Summit in
India but it was an unscheduled meeting
with the Chinese Premier Li Chang that
was making the headlines after a report
back in Britain about alleged Chinese
Espionage within Parliament
well obviously can't comment on the
specifics of an ongoing investigation
but with regard to my meeting with uh my
family what I said very specifically is
that I arranged a raise a range of
different concerns that we have in areas
of disagreement and in particular my
very strong concerns about any
interference in our parliamentary
democracy which is obviously
unacceptable Chinese media said Premier
League told Mr sunac that each country
should properly handle disagreements and
respect each other's core interests and
major concerns it followed a report in
the Sunday Times newspaper that a
parliamentary researcher a British
national in his late 20s who'd spent
time in China earlier in his career had
been arrested in March the Metropolitan
Police confirmed an arrest had been made
along with that of another man in his
30s the researcher is said to have had
links to the security minister Tom
tugenhad who reportedly severed ties
with him before taking up his
ministerial post last year and with the
fellow conservative Member of Parliament
Alicia Kearns seen here in Taiwan last
year chair of the employee essential
Foreign Affairs select committee both
MPS have taken a tough line on China One
Source quoted in the Sunday Times
article said the researcher had been
trying to blunt such views within
Parliament the arrest sharpens a divide
in British politics and particularly
within the governing conservative party
over just how to pursue relations with
Beijing
last month Britain's foreign secretary
became the first in five years to visit
Beijing a decision that upset some
members of his own party critical of
engaging too closely
when it comes to the issue of China our
position is a very cautious and
calibrated one it's one to say that
China is an Epoch defining challenge in
other words you can't wish it away you
know China is the second biggest economy
what happens in that economy affects
jobs lives and livelihoods here in the
UK in June Ken McCallum the head of
Britain's MI5 security service called
China's Communist Party the most
game-changing challenge that Britain
faced
a month later a committee of MPS
reported that the government was
under-resourced to confront what it
called prolific and aggressive targeting
by Chinese intelligence Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera London
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera